reprise demain c'est de pas très vite
avec le témoignage des français dont la
présence ce soir les conduit à
l'annulation de la première condamnation
de batteries des explications anelka n'a
pas su convaincre
lors de cette première semaine souvent
maladroit et malmenée par la vie des 10%
dès le début de ce troisième procès a
clamé son innocence
d'un autre côté les auteurs de l'époque
ont tous aussi été difficile
la deuxième semaine qui s'ouvre demain
s'annonce donc cruciale car pour la
première fois il sera question de la
contre enquête menée l'an dernier 143
bientôt des nouvelles expertises
la preuve que francis heaulme le tueur
en série se trouvait non loin du lieu du
crime toujours là mais cela ne suffit
pas à troubler les avocats des crèmes
pizza une constante dans tous ces
déclarations la seule constante
j - c qui dit je n'ai pas tué deux
enfants dont le tueur en série viendra
témoigner mercredi devant la cour
d'assises de lieux autre témoignage
essentiel qui pourrait lui aussi faire
basculer ce procès celui de deux
pêcheurs et un ans après les faits se
souviennent avoir croit dit francis ou
le meut le soir du drame le visage tâché
de sang et les regards